alors que le pire est à venir maintenant
c'est l'interview nul on a vu ça dans
les prix ngalle bien pour l'aider à
olivier si vous voyez qu'à un moment il
a du mal en tant que vieux copain de
débauche vous pouvez les les voilà alors
est-ce que vous préfériez votre père ou
votre mère à ses interviews nul je les
ai prévenus
je préférais mes grands mères ouais le
mot le plus con en amour pour vous c'est
merci alors où oui oui
alors heureuse et pour vous alors oui
pour toi c'est quoi je vous le plus
condamant moi je tamponne
imaginez que vous croisiez un
extraterrestre le matin comme ça alors
acheter des cigarettes
il vous dit t'es qui toi vous répondez
quoi et toi si vous étiez en vente dans
un sex shop vous sauriez quoi on vend
dans un secteur maginez vous soyez quoi
comme objet un préservatif mais je vais
vous dire pourquoi parce que c'est
exactement la même chose que les
metteurs en scène les préservatifs
ça rassure quand on dort mal mais quand
il y en a pas qu'est ce que c'est bon
maintenant une question nul qui m'a été
envoyé par email parce que vous pouvez
m'envoyer des questions notamment par
gym de béthune savez vous pourquoi les
abribus n'abrite pas les bus je veux
vivre à la question si vous aviez un
fait rentrer chez vous voulu apprendre
briller quelle phrase tu à fermer le gaz
tu as pensé la capote ou coco arrête là
coco je la prendrai est et à qui
attribue riez vous le plus de
circonstances atténuantes
un vieux qui se tape des jeunes où un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles il le
vieux qui stoppe diriez way
alors vous préféreriez passé la nuit
avec anne sinclair lors sinclair ou
brett sinclair
ben je vivais l'irak cinquième ce que je
dois à l'épaule et deux au fait ça lui
fera plaisir et vous carso moi je trouve
ça je veux pas passer la nuit toute
façon non c'est moi j'ai toujours vu ces
choses là comme une livraison mais c'est
d'y accueillir une heure d'arrivée une
heure de départ
je vais vous les chiens une question
michel drucker public r oui oui je
raconte
oui tout ce qu on dit généralement vous
êtes bientôt le voir de coeur je vais
bientôt le mois entraînez vous à vous la
poser le brasseur conversation avec mon
père
avec son agenda